come to this video playing calamus
calamus from the UK to 202 and we got an
open Sicilian let's see is probably
playing at the time on off a success the
time on our hands yeah the modern way to
play this is with f3 but I'm not an
expert with f3 in the can of an English
attack against the terminal this is the
traditional way to play that hmm night
a4 is the move I think
yeah now i can take play Knight b6 this
is how it is play it and yeah now i'm
out of book basically almost i think ii
five and back to see one
mmm yeah be 396 now the e5 pawn can be M
can be an issue
hmm not sure how how do i play this
without b3
be 396 Bishop b2 coincident echt the
pawn
I don't really know how to protect it
maybe maybe I need a form to do that it
feels slightly wrong to play a 4 in this
position simply because it makes my
bishop yeah a bit problematic
yeah but it shouldn't be such a bad
position takes Bishop takes wins the
exchange yeah III square it's of course
very weak night f5 it's a move that I
need to consider let's see however let's
see but I can play here 93 queen age 5
gee 69 h6e cannot take everyone yeah
this is maybe a good idea provoking 93
Queen h5 g6 queen age six and
threatening ed6 made on g7 this could be
could be a good idea and it definitely
doesn't want me to take on a 5 pretty
sure about that
hmm yeah he went for that after all yeah
now we need to react but I wonder still
what the motivation is here forum for
black and threatening ed6 and meet on g7
this is why I cannot take on everyone
and what is black smooth now i also have
rook f3h 3 as a possible idea to improve
yeah the sum at least keeps them
diagonal closed hmm now wonder I wonder
if there's something better even what
about f5 just playing very brutal
that's very close to to work working
maybe it is working really and winning
f-5e takes f we had this always this e
six idea at the end
yeah it's not it's probably it is very
interesting at five but it's not
necessary i can just play that I think
and Brooke age three is a very big very
big threat that he does not react to
strangely enough yeah now he cannot take
with the rook because I rook takes III
the bishop on b2 is the decider yeah but
after pawn takes some I I'm just winning
bishop g6 and there's too much too much
going on against the king so Brooke f6
gives away the piece but he was I think
lost anyway I maybe night f9 to g4 maybe
Nyjah for was possible
okay so he's playing on because of the
time situation look f2
yeah you care to but I'm just playing we
should see one
rook f to Bishop age six and then we'll
give one to simplify matters
check
and tend to go to e5 here and maybe
Bishop d6 but i have work g4 yeah okay
if he goes to somewhere else a 70 b6
rookie five that takes the pawn and I
III the check okay
Bishop c4 coming check and now shine
markings Bishop f6
visual six is almost made
check check check check check check
check check check check black perfect on
time I know it's a maid coming I will
manage in one second but it always gets
a bit shaky if you're down to those very
very low seconds at the end always play
real rubbish when you know we are just a
bottle will step the tournament okay
let's check I think this is this is
still a theoretical position some years
ago i actually had this on the Border's
black hair somehow stumbled into that
okay and now this fo I don't really I
believe that this is great but rather
quickly I got a good position you know
here Bishop d3 is an interesting news
this looks like very accommodating are
very interesting very interesting
computer line it's let's have a look
instead of that he has an interesting
suggestion or it has an interesting
suggestion
so let's have a look and it is to take
and now after Bishop takes just check
here check and wide widths according to
the machine yeah that's possible I mean
white is certainly better winning is not
so clear to me but it's a very strong
attack and nice material wise but I
don't think this is this is too bad
interestingly enough the comp gives
black a clear head share the same I
cannot believe it all prick very hard to
believe
it looks very dangerous for black look
f3 mmm yeah def def is not good okay
this is Sir this I believe it wants to
take I didn't really consider that it
looked far too dangerous to me but the
computer says that this is perfectly
good for black
hmm er possible possible and this is
probably not not really a player move
because of
giving us clearly better for black by
the comp yeah that's not one hundred
percent clear cut because of the very
strong bishop always attacking the six
point yeah then this is shaky i
overestimated my position really yeah
here ok this is really blundering it he
can play Knight g4 95 and continue why
this substantially better but not
winning alright thanks for watching